I think that one might be Polynesian
sauce like this looks like I don't even
know what that word is pop what honestly
I have like very few passes and fast
food is definitely one of them
I'm ashamed to admit it but I love fast
food so much
over the summer I ate so much fast food
I even have all the ABS downloads in my
phone so I know 2 exclusive feels
everything in it I feel like I could
distinguish yeah like types of sauces
and then where the sauces came from
that's gonna be the tricky part for me
I'm pretty confident I was born for this
I was not they're all the same sauce
that kind of me up I thought it these
were all different sauces this one's
like whoa Luther booth it's all coming
back my childhood even ducks on oh yeah
it does look like duck sauce the only
way to have like Chinese food it's like
orange it's a well team definitely not
McDonald's I feel like we're doing a
wine tasting right yes Oh the notes of
tang no cinnamon what fast food
restaurants are there Saco Bell Wendy's
Oh
chick-fil-a I've never been to Wendy's I
think this is McDonald I think this is
Wendy's
I mean this one's McDonald's this one's
like 10 to 3 or something
chick-fil-a chick-fil-a they have lines
and everything yes wish we had some
chicken nuggets or never hMMF those
abilities there's a lot her I'm willing
to bet my life on that it's perfume
infused or soap you don't taste like
lavender I feel like at this point they
all face today
another close ketchup one - oh it's all
I have someone was close to catch up and
it was chick-fil-a McDonald's
Burger King izella McDonald's no bounds
Birkin AHA I knew it I was like it
tasted like the last word oh I'm
disappointing everyone I love honey
mustard is my favorite sauce in the
world okay right off the bat these all
have very different color me up this
one's gonna be my favorite I can already
tell
that's chick-fil-a I don't even need to
try it colors textures that one has
polka dots the bones your dogs have to
like speckle look to it which ones have
been fix up our Burger King Burger Kings
has been why I got him
I figured it out whoa that's good that's
Burger King do you think that's Burger
King I have no idea what I'm saying I'm
smoking spice smokey spice yeah let me
just look at it and like if I was this
sauce where would I be
smokey spice is the next spice girl I
wonder if there's anyone that's like
really good at it
I think those winnings with all those
Burger King mm-hmm
[Music]
signature we don't get the Big Mac sauce
right like I don't know what we should
do well I can tell you all right this is
chick-fil-a sauce I was like to see
their salad sauce oh it looks like this
this came from chopped honestly that is
feels like Hidden Valley what are these
names now that's what I'll put on my
burger mmm I like that which ones to
pick my song none of these taste like
the Big Mac sauce I'm gonna make up for
all my failures right now I feel like
we're gonna miss love I'm just gonna go
for it are you ready I don't think this
is gonna oh it's gonna work just believe
in me I don't even know I just forgot
chick-fil-a Wendy's Taco Bell Burger
King McDonald's
[Music]
or this challenge in particular like I'm
half proud that I didn't get all of them
right that was one of the most difficult
things I've ever done I thought this is
like my one expertise I could go for
some chicken covered in honey mustard
right now actually the chicken just
without this off like I have all the
sauce I need inside so let's just do the
chicken yeah
[Music]